die arktis erlebt im moment den wärmsten
winter seit dem es wetterbeobachtungen
gibt es seit 1980 steigen dort die
temperaturen aus dem minusbereich immer
weiter in die plusgrade und das schlimme
ist dass sich dieser prozess
beschleunigt wie ist also die lage am
nordpol und wie sehen die auswirkungen
für uns auf jetzt den blick zum science
fiction herzlich willkommen
wenn man den klimawandel bei seinem
fortschreiten beobachten will dann geht
das im moment wohl am besten in der
arktis hier galoppieren die temperaturen
nahezu nach oben seit den 80er jahren
gibt es dort eine rasante entwicklung
die für dramatische wetterphänomene auch
hier in europa sorgt und jetzt ist ein
neuer rekord erreicht worden
während wir hier zumindest in berlin mal
wieder nach jahren richtige kälte hatten
ist die entwicklung am nordpol eine ganz
andere
die wetterstation kate moss ob am
nördlichsten punkt grönlands mars jetzt
temperaturen über null und das im winter
zum teil war es dort sogar wärmer als
hier in deutschland mit 6,1 grad celsius
für das arktische polareis bedeutet dass
schmelze und das bedeutet dass das
meerwasser frei liegt und sich durch die
sonneneinstrahlung noch weiter aufwärmen
in der region gab es seit 1979 nie
weniger eis und es wird noch immer
weniger es scheint so als würde der
polarwirbel der für die niedrigen
temperaturen sorgen sollte so langsam
immer schwächer und er kann eben nicht
mehr für die nötige kälte sorgen
in grönland wurden in diesem winter 61
stunden über null grad celsius gemessen
das ist drei mal so viel wie in allen
bisherigen wintern im schnitt so warm
war es noch nie in der arktis zitat was
wir hier beobachten ist eine
herausragende anomalie die weit
außerhalb der historischen beobachtung
liegt und daher sehr beunruhigend ist es
lässt weitere klimatische überraschung
für die zukunft befürchten dass sagt
michael mann vom system science center
von der pennsylvania state university
und mal wieder ist es der abgeschwächten
jetstream der in den usa immer wieder
für schlimme schneestürme sorgt aber an
anderer stelle für wärmerekorde durch
die langsame geschwindigkeit des
jetstreams werden seine wellen stärker
die sogenannten roski wellen die jetzt
kalte luft weiter in den süden bringen
und auf dem rückweg warme luft von
weiter her nach norden
zitat in den vergangenen 50 jahren ist
das phänomen sowohl eine der
intensivsten als auch eine der am
längsten anhaltenden wärme werden die je
im arktischen winter beobachten werden
konnten so robert roode wissenschaftler
beim berkeley earth surface temperature
projekt gegenüber dem guardian für uns
in europa hat diese entwicklung
dramatische folgen
durch die eisfreie arktis wird
verursacht dass durch die wärme auch
immer mehr wasser verdunstet über europa
regnet es dann ab
und sorgt wird dramatische unwetter mit
bisher noch nie dagewesenen regenmenge
es dürfte in den nächsten jahren in
europa immer ungemütlicher werden wir
sollten uns auf immer mehr
wetterkatastrophen einstellen wenn er
als erstes neues zum thema klimawandel
und die folgen für europa und zu allen
anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet
meine telefonnummer bei whatsapp dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt
dort direkt über mich in der redaktion
vom krieg somit machen wir themen
vorschlagen oder an abstimmungen
teilnehmen und mitbestimmen passierbar
klicks und passiert der direkte draht zu
mir einfach hier draufklicken dann geht
quasi alles wie von selbst und natürlich
nicht das abo mit der genau vergessen
hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken klimawandel bewiesen
skeptiker endgültig widerlegt ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran